this is jürgen trittin
he is bundestagsabgeordneter from the green
and was even once bundesumweltminister
mr.
trittin please finish the sentence
a minister of the environment
must be charming and combative nowadays
my average speed on the highway is
very rarely on the highway
I do not know
i also don't have a driver's license at all oha
christian lindner i guess
recognize the reality and
to from synthetic fuels
to adopt
Minister dosenpfand call me today
only most people still call me dj can deposit
unlike crete thunberg i am missing
pots science should be used in politics
be taken seriously
the biggest challenge in climate change
is
make is like want only more blatant